this is the first time in my two years
you've been here on time and welcome to
punch-drunk sports everybody's doing
something Tebow's on Grindr ah
johnny is looking for the n-word videos
because he loves hearing people droppin
bombs and I am son out guns out bow
Bleus Raider Jersey boob a lot of great
stuff going on man it's a great time of
your life I'm super excited by does it
Johnny looks like you took too big of a
bong hit anything over high looking at
your [ __ ] you're like you're like so
high you drool you're like nope nobody's
what man that one quit slamming em hey
you don't tell me I'll work my mic oh
well your buddy Ryan didn't yeah little
note on the on my ass I'm a piece
allowed today is a piece of [ __ ] Sam day
how are you guys solid we're doing great
Johnny doing great what are you talking
about you got a serious farmers dangling
look like you just been mowing the lawn
like all summer and then you got a tank
top and yeah that's like I said that was
like 16 dollars right there what that
was pretty cheap probably around that
most like I was most likely more but
it's okay I like it it's the kind of
[ __ ] that give away at the end no they
don't give these away
this is offense like rather knowing
where the name comes my back it says
coca-cola
I got a Bulls Jersey but back in the day
but you had to be like 12 or under and
those I got Jordan Jersey but in the
back it just said coca-cola and when I
got on my [ __ ] they're giving away like
replicas Jordan jerseys just like the
greatest game to go to and I got it and
I held it up and turn around I was gonna
say Jordan is cocka Co I'm like look at
my ass kicked if I wear this to school
I don't wearing this to seventh grade
I'm gonna get the [ __ ] stomped out of me
so you okay coca-cola Chuck so the
went into a lot of Bulls games how far
away from Chicago did you grow up like
about a 40 40 minute train ride but if
you drove that was like before the
United States was like Chicago Stadium
so you know you could drive there
probably less than an hour I was a lot
of Bulls games don't oppose games before
that Jordan and then his rookie season
all that amazing yeah it was great
must have been a man and then once he
got really good even before they want
Championships you know once I had Horace
Grant and Pippen and he started to put
pieces together then it got kind of like
hard to get ticket then it became like
the hip thing to do but before that even
his rookie or in a second year you can
get tickets in the night of the game
yeah you know and then once they got
good then it was then once it was how
expensive did the Lakers tickets get
with LeBron didn't they like jump up and
it's like insane let's check with our
good comments yeah see geek seeking
seeking for all your ticketing needs go
to see geek
download the app use the promo code here
it is how much junk is it yeah yeah and
that gets you 20 bucks off your first
purchase which is great it get the app
because what are you gonna do carry your
laptop around and look sure that's all
carrying a mainframe with you get the
app wherever you are in the country
whatever you're doing wherever you are
in the world you can look up yeah
tickets up a guaranteed they're not
gonna be and I gotta get shim-sham like
all these other websites yes well that's
designed to make your ticket buying
experience easier than ever by searching
multiple ticket sites and grading each
ticket based on value see geek helps you
immediately identify the best seats that
fit your budget Plus every purchase is
fully guaranteed so shop for tickets on
seek with confidence and it doesn't end
with sports seeking has playing concerts
comedy comedy dude you love comedy hate
it I actually you see cake I got Allison
chains tickets
the final band of all the bands I wanted
to see that I haven't seen finally gonna
go seem at the end of the month at the
Palladium
thanks to see geek $60 ticket teach so
guys I guess you've now
every band you want to see yeah yeah
yeah best of all our listeners get $20
off their seeking purchase just by using
posture so you can go and see LeBron and
instead of it being $3,000 now it's only
two thousand nine hundred and eighty
dollars thanks Iggy is that awesome okay
these are the cheapest season tickets
they went from thirty five hundred
dollars to fifty eight hundred dollars
and one guy spent a hundred and eighty
eight thousand dollars to purchase four
season tickets really but he is sitting
in the middle of the floor he's sitting
he's literally half court in the middle
of the floor they have to play around
him would it be great if they it was
kind of like the m1 tournament where you
can actually pay to be the guy in the
mic and going the professor right the
whole time yeah that would be good what
do you think that would I would just
hack all and just hack all the Lakers
let's look for a big game here good
there I think Christmas they play Golden
State I bet that's gonna be a high
ticket right there what are your guys in
San Francisco what are your guys
thoughts and I know it's not basketball
season but what do you guys how do you
think the Lakers team plays out - your
hatred of up yet and take an honest one
like I had six six I think with all of
the television stuff he's doing they're
gonna be [ __ ] they're gonna be [ __ ] man
he's got so many anyways I think the
Clippers gonna be [ __ ]
I think anyways can you open the door oh
my god fight man II can't open the door
how you supposed to raise a baby if you
can't open the door for the baby oh my
god that's for babies [ __ ] by the way
what do they call the bran fans brownies
bronies [ __ ]
brunettes he's a baby he can't even open
a door why did that always lock it like
I got locked out the other day - guys
welcome to the show she just pumping out
kids just adding to the traffic fight
are you guys are you working have it no
that's like crazy to me there are people
that do that like yeah they're called
rich white people yeah true
what are you looking for Johnny just
looking to see what's offensive highest
ISO it doesn't like the door wasn't
really locked by the way you hadn't be
like Vince I'm like what am I doing
wrong
no I knew his lock why didn't know his
lock but once you couldn't get in
because I happened to me the other week
fine Annie how are you what's new we're
going to Boston for 10 days today Oh
today today what time 8:00 tonight so
you're gonna go there and then what do
you fly back then go to Vegas for the
fight no I'm not going are you are we
going you guys going I'm going
I'd like to go I'm thinking about
renting a Airbnb that would be really
fun should we should I do that
gonna be interesting I throw everybody
in the car like what happened well we're
gonna have fun I do want a baby in the
car cuz then yeah bring the baby man get
some fantastic you start in the trunk
with the other baby in the trunk I guess
I won't be at your show tonight by the
way oh [ __ ] yeah great thanks tell us
now those are my favorite things to do
to sit back and just watch me scream at
Dana
watching get Dana hammered that part
it's happy birthday Dana Marshall
birthday I go to Boston talked to her
boss and baby's gonna come back with a
already bad bad that's the best thing
she came back from Boston BAM not
thirsty MA
that's it of the worst Boston accent or
Santa in the middle of a stroke that was
a baby with the boss man man baby man a
baby or a Boston accent
it's like you ask somebody who doesn't
know what a Boston accent is and has
never seen a baby before his life oh my
god so what else is up Aaron did you see
that walk-off Grand Slam against
Washington Cubs he saw the Cardinal I
saw the one last night everybody same
team the Nationals they gave up wall
cops back-to-back games dude walk-off
Grand Slam walk-off homer listen the
Dodgers closer gets a heart problem we
blow four straight games in the ninth
lovely love it ok we're in trouble
doctors might not make the postseason
all those trades yeah all that I'll let
that checkbook great players money
what's magic magic spent too much time
trying to get LeBron here forgot about
his other team I don't think he's in the
front office Oh
yep great guy can get free agents there
nothing habits it's it's it's not good I
don't know who can't we got no way you
could close yeah that's no that's this
is the time of year what you blame the
management right well I vote yeah well
the managers lost us so many games and
now we might be too far but luckily that
the Diamondbacks are losing as well I
mean Queens got an arm yeah you think
that's funny Aaron or you you throw to
Hernandez anywhere on the field so you
might as well have oh dude I think you
did earlier this year oh you did yeah
you pitched a Phillies gave up the game
in the 16th inning yeah yeah I mean it's
16 at some point you're like this all go
home yeah go home I hope they missed the
playoffs by one game and then they look
back at that what happened to you like
who touched you I don't I uh diddle well
you sound like a baby from Bossa uh yeah
nobody sounds like a baby from boss no
human any yeah yeah yeah
hey Jason where you gonna be
I'm going to be this Friday big news at
the red zone thank you very much
football is officially back Jack we'll
talk a little fantasy later we're gonna
figure out how we're gonna get this
league going but that's about it
it's about it uh tomorrow night I am at
the comedy palace jim Florentine Kate
Quigley Carlisle Foster the comedy
rampage tickets are sell I'm pretty
excited about that so they'll be at the
comedy palace in San Diego come get some
following night I am at the dojo at
10:00 p.m. again jim Florentine same
show you can grab those tickets on
Eventbrite should be amazing and then I
just want to push the big shows that are
coming up September 5th tinfoil hat
comedy night with Eddie Bravo Theo von
Aaron's gonna be there up on stage being
the [ __ ] voice of anti reason or and
Ryan Davis will be in the belly room
that's September 5th 8 p.m. and then
September 14 to 15 a days the tinfoil
hat
comedy night and we are at Niagara Falls
Canada tickets are selling so go grab
them now we are at the corner comedy
club just go to the corner comedy club
com grab your tickets now it's going to
be fun on the Canadian side of the falls
yeah which is kind of like the San Diego
side of Tijuana San Diego yeah I mean
literally it's like the falls are like
now you're in America yeah but either
side of the river to like the one side
is very grey the other side is bright
and clean and like shiny it's very
interesting but I'm excited should be
fun should be fun
can we talk about ESPN and how they just
think women love talking sports do you
ever with any of your female friends
just go to see the game last night what
what is with these baseball shifts never
you guys know that any girls to that any
girls that talk just love to sit down
talk I know any girls that just flex in
the middle of a sentence yeah
I know one the Boston baby strangler
over yeah yeah yeah Mac give me Boston
Bay bistro the Boston babies strangler
do why aren't there more baby serial
killers they are hard there are even
they call they're called black fathers
is that what you're saying I resemble
that what do you want you didn't - dude
I want to talk a little [ __ ] what's our
goal
I thought we were talking about babies
here Lou I just can't take it's like 24
hours of I literally do not watch yeah I
probably haven't seen ESPN and they
cater to women
I can't even dude I guess young acts
like women can't top stop talking sports
it's unbelievable like every every
buddies there are more women talking
sports on ESPN than not on ESPN like
hosting shows on yeah yeah and then
they're talking to each other like Sarah
tell me about what you've learned while
you know through my Reese this is the
most unnatural conversation people get
mad at a gay straight guy who just got
cast as a gay guy in a big movie that's
more realistic than two chicks
talk to each other about sports or
pushing you guys who are the real fans
away I'm gone I they're not even pushing
me away I've been done with the SPN for
a long time if I want anything I just go
their website get highlights that's it
and for me to do that they're like hey
watch this home run and you know and if
he has the N feed that comes on so I
click it and it's a 70 minute second
commercial that I can't skip through and
then the highlight is four seconds long
you know what I do if I got my
headphones on them on my computer and
I'm one of those two it'd take my
headphones off and I'd look away yeah
both you guys are fighting the power in
your own separate way I refuse to watch
their advertising I refuse to watch it
well when you force people to watch
something it actually makes it so you
never want to buy that product the one
that really makes me mad is well there's
a particular commercial on YouTube
that I have several times looked up and
it's this old super racist commercial
from Chicago that they still air today
for this place called Moomin oink
now what Moomin oink is is this huge
like warehouse for like soul food like
you can get like 20 pound bag of chips
rose and chicken wings for like 6 bucks
it's like Sam's Club and it's on the
south side it's terrible but their
commercial is insanely but they run it
still still and it's like hilarious for
my case yeah
no no it's just in general but my point
is or a movie so that one or a movie
trailer that's it or a movie trailer I
want to look up a movie trailers which
is a commercial that YouTube plays a
commercial this is it yeah YouTube makes
you watch a commercial this is great
[Music]
it's amazing Jim McMahon to do the rap
on so that's been playing since I was a
kid it still plays so sometimes I look
that up but do you guys if you look on
you to your barn I think it's like white
and black I remember this one too have
you ever seen yeah this is exactly I'm
talking about I'm looking up a
commercial that was my whole point a
movie trailer is a commercial I'm
seeking out your advertising and you
make me watch a longer commercial than
the commercial I'm looking up [ __ ] you
YouTube
I love it this is great right here to
the credit I think it's in North
Carolina those guys are comics those two
guys pictures of money all the time this
is the greatest thing that's ever
happened to me it's meant to be funny
Bravo cuz those two guys are like
YouTube celebrities that's my goal
that's my goal with and all the
commercials are quite similar but
commercials like that is my goal for
9275 you know to me all the jingles and
it's like that's every commercial I want
to come across like that can we um
could we find more of those commercials
as long as they have an angle look up
most racist commercial actually it's
gotta be that but tune that moon like I
would actually watch commercials if
every commercial was like that I would
watch it no problem what if what if that
exact is listening going
let's now engage there
well hell we go really race oh no this
is the racist this is probably the most
racist room this one this Japanese you
guys all know all these it's not often
that you don't see something like this
he's shocked
[Music]
oh yeah this is great
it's tough the black guy no washing
machine
and he comes out Asian what century guys
again people don't realize how racist
Asians are absolutely oh they're very
because they're just Asians don't go hey
dude I know black people nobody knows
any black people
oh yeah they don't know anybody and
you're races against himself to see the
one where the guy walks up in these uh
the the the arm what's that one mask
that the scary Matt the scary dream
scream mask walks up to the asian lady
goes oh she doesn't do anything they
takes off and it's a black guy she's
like oh boy
by the way sales of this washing machine
went through the roof I'm sure of course
if you could do that
wash the black out of the only black guy
and so weird thing was that in Sony in
China just in the American South oh yeah
rude yeah they all went to kit the
Carolinas he was awfully dry I just want
to say isn't someone looking at
particular true what was the mud and the
weird like makeup on his fancy stuff
laundry soap in their mouth black I was
way more attractive to I wouldn't like
Oh somebody somebody's got jungle fever
and I turn up and turned a regular black
guy into it shine you should have one of
everything you got the white guy
[Laughter]
Asians are raised welcome to Asian
racist podcast we should just do hold
segments how racists are Asian all right
that's enough with fun with racism
anymore I guess on ATC tracks just tweet
us any cool funny commercials we'll play
them if you get some good ones find them
on Twitter tweet us at fun strong at
punch drunk that's punch drunk punch
drunk I'm pretty sure they know our
Twitter so guys what do we uh what do we
think about we're leading up daring up
for the NFL ah do we have any thoughts
on anything about the NFL yeah
preseason can suck it yeah I mean say
Quan Barkley already uh he's he'll be
fine pull the hammy
well one guy whose kid his outfit season
I'd like the Redskins their rocky
running back yeah yeah he was nice or
whatever yeah he was the guy that got in
trouble because he said he made up right
he made up things that they asked he
said that the NFL teams asked them and
they weren't real all right
hey do you like in the butt they ask
incredibly stupid things though are you
top or a bottom do this maybe a young
girl you ever stole crab legs
oh [ __ ] he's in trouble I mean he's that
well he's got three games but I don't I
think I I'm starting to think my
original thoughts about him are right
what that he's dad's cool that image his
problem is what to meet I never liked
his problem is what's in between his
ears well dude this is gonna be the
first hard knocks and you watch hard
knocks and there's gonna be the first
season where everybody's not like
thinking this thing's gonna be really
good like it's a [ __ ] [ __ ] show I
don't know you I don't the Tecla man out
yet is it no this is the first one Wow
does it I think it's like Tuesday okay I
used to be Sunday to probably like this
associate but then the new one wasn't
out yesterday or so don't you love how
everybody new to the team is like oh do
we I get tougher the we're like screwed
Hoover Cleveland yeah well I think their
problem
isn't talent I think their problem is no
one is behind their coach or all of
their coaches the sixteenth that comes
out so what's it
Thursday that's weird yeah there was
like two that's like two weeks in
between them is something you don't well
I think the first one comes out on Hard
Knocks there's only been one I was
trying to shoot when the second one you
know the last one came out on the 9th
and this one comes out with 16th
according to this anyway okay
well no that's no [ __ ] that's last year
at Surry anyway did yet have you seen it
- yeah yeah Jackson's just not good he's
not good he's a good position coach but
a manager of an entire organization no
no no and then you got Todd we're great
really Todd Hayley who's obviously a
[ __ ] starter well he hates dude yet you
can tell like from nobody he's never
been like anywhere this guy plays anyone
anywhere this guy coaches he gets ran
out cuz he just says let's just face it
man feet of football coaches the last
place America you could be a [ __ ]
Jackson as well you know Jackson's same
thing he's would run out everywhere
oh yeah when he made the trade for a lot
of talent Cleveland so money first they
had so many draft picks right Oliver
yeah mm-hmm I mean they have a lot of
talent it's just like [ __ ] man I mean
that's everything with the Falcons if
the Falcons don't put up a lot of points
in these first four or five games
I think sarkeesian's gonzo really do
they have too much money I can't believe
I mean before the season thing no no I
mean during the season preseason sucks I
mean you know with coordinators it's
very rare you get fired on your first
season because of the transition well
last year did they do any kind of like
did that he did he go from the field to
the booth anything did they try to
switch anything up yeah that'll be the
next thing probably right wherever I
don't know if he's on the field or in
the booth but they'll just they always
switch that around before yeah I think
yeah I I don't know we'll see I mean we
have a lot there's no reason Atlantic
can't score a lot but I mean you weren't
looking forward to him coming in anyway
right you I'm kind of remember well I
didn't want to lose
didn't definitely didn't know I didn't
want to lose Shanahan for sure I mean I
remember a lot of we had the nationally
the best often seen I felt like top 10
of all time two years ago so you're
gonna have a drop-off Matt Ryan's
destroyed my fantasy team for half a
season that's just remember and then
your wide receiver I'm Mario Mario Garza
yeah he's garbage I told you that
Troopers garbage yeah Cooper's garbage
there he is
joining us in studio friend up show some
Christian Warrior you just listen this
guy going off on the Milwaukee Brewers
please welcome my good friend I love
this guy - - Sam Tripoli okay like that
it's three to zero Brewers are up first
inning thank you very much who are you
guys playing with the Cubs are the White
Sox Oh
Kubby Dodgers great no I think since
all-star week before the all-star break
know I'm very aware I've I just got a
text I can name drop it as a big star
just text me today we are very much
baseball guys and I just told him I said
the team is just blows Council as the
worst manager I said that the the
organization did nothing during the you
know to pick up someone during the
deadline nothing no deadline nothing
happened with the Brewers organization
I'm from walking I'm a die-hard and I've
there's never been a World Series hi
what's your name thanks for coming on -
Sam - you're a wonderful person I always
enjoy seeing you anytime we get to talk
I think I just think you're wonderful do
not always enjoy like when we're getting
together you have great energy and and
when I see you on Twitter just melting
down I love it because like I am I'm a
Raiders I'm a Dodgers fan but I'm also a
Clippers fan which is McCann relate to
small market teams being the Clipper
family because you know we're kind of
like cast aside it's like so hard for us
to ever be good because we're living in
like the Lakers
shadow so
when I see like how much passion you
have for the Milwaukee Brewers I just
realized like it's so must be so hard to
be a small-market team fan it is but
those are the real diehards Ron kid a
lot of bandwagon brewer fans now you get
bandwagon Cubs fans but you didn't yeah
Cubs were never a small-market team they
were just a fuck-off organization but I
always think tit like when you're in a
big market town I mean it's hard to say
that Clippers are a small-market team
when it they're in Los Angeles right but
but cement the Mets are a small-market
team because in a in a two team town
there's one that gets everything and
then there's the [ __ ] redheaded
stepchild that's always been the Cubs
the Mets the Clippers the mitts the Mets
and the Chargers now are gonna be the
similar in that the the other team in
town happens to be the gold standard of
that sport the Lakers and Yankees tip
but there's a reason of her sports and
that I I'm from Milwaukee a small market
town so my parents passed away my dad
had in sports if you go to talent
Milwaukee there's not a lot they live
for sports in there in the the most
loyal fans anestachio is the owner
I call him pistachio or a statio now he
bought the team he's genius because he
knows were the seventh in that small
market were the seventh highest
attendance right now and it's gonna pass
three million probably uh well they
should all of base in all baseball
so that's small because people are loyal
and they just are loyal so we had my dad
at forty four tickets to Packer games we
had two restaurants he did his best
customers I grew up with his passion of
he had 44 ticket through Packer games
and was best customers you know once a
year there lay in Milwaukee back then
and I saw him it's like half and half so
they split they really yeah we used to
be at County Stadium half the they split
it up Milwaukee and Green Bay so I'd go
to these as a little kid and he'd get a
bus and take the fans to the games they
would just drink brandy and beer so
that's how you have loyalty and that's
why I'm passionate so I've never seen a
championship with the like the Brewers
or I've seen the Packers win Super Bowl
but well you're from there you just
become you know I saw box at a heyday
back in the day you know that's the NBA
blows now it just it felt like yeah I
like it but I know that they'll never
have a success even though they have to
an estoppel or whatever it did the Greek
yeah Greek great I got this great guy
but is nothing will happen
he'll go he'll go for miles I know I
think he said he said he's dedicating
walking plus to be him for seven years
for sure what's his life he's bought a
third world dude I know he's from Greece
but he's from like the Sudan or some
[ __ ] like that yeah so those are the
people when we're talking to MBA those
are the guys that these small market
teams have to get where they haven't had
in their head beating down you gotta get
to the big market yeah
like small market teams and the MBA
can't get these AAU guys who the whole
time been told you gotta get to Lakers
gotta get to know everybody wants to go
to Knicks even though it kills your
career because it's just because they
try to operate like the Yankees which is
by everybody and that's not that's not
how basketball works basketball is like
you got to grow pieces together um just
the Brewers are just I love the team I
love that you have the passion for the
team do you ever go to Dodger games yeah
I just watch the Dodger Brewers series
oh is that the only time you go to see
the doctor no no I said just a few times
so I've seen the Dodgers I I hate the
Dodgers I don't like anything I do I
like what's a cow say look you know my
back I was gonna be I want to be a pro
ballplayer really I played it Wisconsin
I played it Wisconsin Eau Claire the
second-biggest cool I made the varsity
of my freshman year I did the state for
high school baseball as a pitcher did
you play college yeah and then I I said
I got to go to Cal State Fullerton this
guy by the name of Augie Garrido was the
coach at the time so I went and tried
out I went to the team and it was uh at
that time they were scrimmaging Mark
McGwire and he was at USC and these guys
were massive just yeah we know why
whiskers tell I was 38 years old she got
a she got him way earlier she got a like
14 and so I I did the so I tried out
because I thought it was pretty good I
had this knuckle curveball and no one
could hit it and I could throw 89 miles
an hour at that time was good not bad it
amazed no 89 and then I did a I when I
turned 30 I couldn't make the pro so I
did this league where they had guys that
played like a long hunt you you didn't
give up the dream of baseball and I get
30 no no I still played baseball but Cal
State Fullerton I didn't MIT I said
these guys are amazing
yeah you know these I didn't have the
muscles than that so I started getting
in the theater and emceeing stuff and I
was like this your great MC dude
I like to do oh yeah I'd love for you to
have a TV show cuz I think he'd be so
great it I do a show I would do the you
know I travel it's thing called Wizard
World
so my 20th city and I MC I told Chicago
Tuesday but I've been doing these shows
I do nine hours on stage of Comic Con so
we have all the Marvel superheroes the
actors the DC Comics anime and on pop
culture it's the best job ever and it's
just the the fans for Comic Con and
cosplay there's nothing like a monk they
have no judgement they don't judge you
they don't do the Oh Jace nothing they
don't even know the kids now they don't
even they say go who's that dude he's
fun I know yes right here your friends
for the Opera that's was it world
oh dude that's gotta be great give me
all the hot chicks we've got a anime
animation yeah these dresses I don't
even know the characters but I do know
the my thing is when the kids are doing
the cosplay if this Iron Man I go thorry
look great and it goes I'm not door
sorry I posted stuff kiss the kids they
have no they can't this guy doesn't know
who I am I'm Iron Man I'm dressed as no
no you're Thor seriously then they
started asking their parents at my work
do you want some when I was a kid Batman
was in tenth man was gonna be at the
mall almost like a Santa Claus situation
right now my story no no someone dresser
I thought just a regular to gel I'm
probably like six
I'm so [ __ ] excited [ __ ] meet
Batman I thought Batman was a real [ __ ]
and so we were in line and my mom gets
me enlightens long line of kids I
finally get to up to Batman to meet him
and he had this real high squeaky voice
and he's like hi Jason nice to meet you
and I just started crying
and I'm like that's not Batman and all
the kids in line started crying and like
that's not Batman they're yelling at
their parents man that right when I
heard his voice it didn't sound like
Adam West yeah and I knew it was just
some fake guy and I'm like I waited all
right you said [ __ ] [ __ ] oh that's
pretty impressive
I'm sure I did but not in that moment
about the Superman at like Universal
City will hawk and his chant and he's
like he's now he must be hung over
something and he's got super geillis
flying around he can't even get up
it's so funny I got I got a great story
I tell you so I'm I to this gig where I
was on Hollywood Boulevard like doing
man in the street stuff and there's that
you know how they dress up as Chewbacca
yeah Where's Waldo yeah
so I this fight started but I was part
of it I was doing the interviews it was
a fight between like fake Freddy Krueger
and fake Wolverine and fake and a huge
fight a lot of so I had all right I had
all the tape on this and I called the
guy work for it you know elke David yeah
so elke I do this the Holograms and I
did a lot of show tailgating with Kate
oh yeah yeah yeah I go elke I've got
this I got all the video footage every
Network called me and you know you can
sell that he didn't want to sell it I
could have made so much money so Kimmel
got it and it was this huge thing on
Kimmel for the week and then they
interviewed Where's Waldo and they did
the interview how the fight started it
was hysterical it was all my footage
hilarious people don't realize what
chaos Hollywood Boulevard yeah yeah cuz
it's like every tourist destination but
on top of that people who moved there to
be famous and whatever reason they're
drug addictions or whatever not annoying
like characters on a street are the
instigators of insanity they get
arrested like groping chicks like Tickle
Me Elmo I mean that's what it was Pat
woman that's right she got groped in the
ass that's how this started
it was cat woman who was in the fight
she was a chick that was fighting um oh
god it's you could still google it if
you want to do it was the fight the
Kimmel uh oh
because it was it's funny man or
spider-man or someone but it was a
character but these guys you need to do
these interviews when you're in Halle
bolivars they're there every day you
know they want to do a photo they ask
for money they have a 5 because they
need money they do not shower they stink
so bad there in that crackheads my buddy
my but the grand I think I'm a friend of
mine used to work at that wings place
right there what's that Wow Buffalo Wild
Wings he was working there now no
scooters no no it's a little further
down I call I called I called Randolph I
didn't know where he's working I'm like
what are you doing he's like I'm at work
I'm on my break
I'm just watching Superman
crack right across the street and
[ __ ] sent me a picture and there's
[ __ ] Superman sitting indian-style
smoking crack right right on the side
how does them bone before that's gotta
be hilarious oh here we go
yes yes this is that's all my footage
this is say we just gave it to him is
CBS how hilarious is the broad walk of
fame we can't we can't you see oh you
just saw me I think there's a little bit
right here Lee let me show myself okay
where are you so what happened this guy
came up and just grabbed her yeah that's
the girl I work with right there
she was my co-host mr. incredible oh
yeah very Kruger here comes oh here
comes screw vodka why is he fighting the
woman oh she see slap I was there she
came she started in it so he's a guppy
Where's Waldo oh yeah look II went out
there started a disclaimer I don't know
but it did go to court and it did
yeah I hope that was showed up in
costume at court Brett why is brighter
and stressed as mr. incredible just my
nose they kind of dude it's [ __ ]
ridiculous what kind of world we live in
they're like we love the video cut out
Kato Kaelin snows please yes where's
waldo could be a guy or a girl could be
pat or they just missed it because you
then for doing that that's the new union
law I do get scale
oh nice congratulations thank you yeah
it's K and then you got Chewbacca aka
the Armenian right and there's Waldo and
then they interviewed in Kimmel then if
you go to the Kimmel thing then Kimmel
interviews Waldo they found him and how
the fight started he explains the whole
thing hilarious funny Hollywood
interesting yeah it's never what you
think it is Hollywood Boulevard like
when tourists come here and and they're
like but they want to see it and then
after they see it you know they're like
yeah I didn't wouldn't really hang out
there much oh yeah it's not really Times
Square you know I mean I have a friend
stay with you know she's from Beijing
she's just why'd you get a seductive
voice she's like slow first of all she's
gorgeous then we're having an absolute
ball but I'm so glad said because she
has no interest in going every time I
have people come in to Universal Studios
little thing I go no I Venice Beach is
another one to it can't do it anymore I
can't
and and Universal the these the Harry
Potter thing it was really it's nothing
and then you get the Harry Potter Potter
rights 30 like 30 seconds the line is
forever yeah there's a lot of people why
did they go
I guess one Disney I heard Bert
Kreischer and Joe Rogan talk about the
Avatar ride at Disney is supposedly the
most next level right out there alright
scary right so whoo-hoo which one has
the avatar eyes world excuse me world
Disney World
Disney what they say it's amazing they
can afford a trip to Disney World most
of us can't no I can you can yeah yeah
yeah it's they get the yeah you can get
the one day pass at Disney but tourists
aren't there for the one day you go the
whole I don't say crazy expensive
hundred dollars it's like Disney I'm so
excited I listen to it they'll Mel Q for
kids and them lq4 like marriage wife
[ __ ] they'll milky like then when they
know you have to pay little milky like
if I have a kid or something you got to
have a kid like you can't start showing
Mickey Mouse stuff because they don't
know they're gonna grow up in morning
all stuff so show them like paper plates
and you go oh my god I can get I can get
you some key hey what is this why are
you breathing so heavy on your phone
you're here with Kato Kaelin I should
wear these huh
hello yes you should what's up hello Sam
everybody here you back thank you glad
to be here what's the word well I was
just thinking I just read an article and
it gave
you and Tebow there one of the best
chances to win a Super Bowl in the next
five years I'll take that the Falcons
Raiders and Falcons gave Falcons Raiders
put my Packers on their - Packers
Packers were sucking dick at the bottom
how was it the copies are not gonna make
any noise well that guy is via via the
the running or the quarterback area had
to get him off he's breathing so heavy
okay yeah it was what you know I had the
Rams I think I were going to be a Rams
are gonna be good for a while yeah
Allison is he gonna come back - do you
pay a lineman that much more mobile unit
don't know yeah uh yeah he'll get it
I'll get everything would you pay
somebody's one of the best defensive
players to the period you time - 20 mil
I would of so now you got a quarterback
making all that money he may catch it
yeah but he's about to in four years
that's why I give Aaron down oh that's
exactly what they're doing they they got
a young rut running back and a young
quarterback they rode the running back
that till they had to pay him and
they're gonna ride golf for three years
and they're gonna pay everybody and in
three or four years the bottom is gonna
fall out because they're not gonna be
able to afford all these people anymore
so do why you can't get it when you've
got a good rookie quarterback that's
playing for pennies on the dollar
I mean he's what four million dollars a
year when he is gonna be making 17 in
five years a year and then you take all
that other money he's invested in the
defense and receivers and weapons for
him and I'll and you draft linemen I
just so much to pay a [ __ ] lineman
it's just so much you travel for the
radar you good you go to games I might
go this Saturday but you go to the so
before the Vegas move you're all for
that here's my thing I know the Oakland
Raiders we should be playing in the
worst stadium in baseball we're a
premier football team one of the top
brands in the NFL why are we playing in
a baseball stadium and I get that
Oakland doesn't want to pay for a
football stadium and a baseball stadium
and why they'd rather pay
for baseball stadium because that's
actually more games for the locals to
work at ain't compared to what's 80 you
know but we need a real stadium the
Raiders should have their own same the
Raiders should be here it should not be
the charger the charger should be in San
Diego that's my opinion
yeah well I'm very connection to the
Raiders and I do the ability coffee
tournament every year so I do fret
butakov golf charity I know all the
Raiders I am seed the other Jeremy
needed Chewbacca for that or no well if
I go this year you can go but uh oh my
god the Titan hi I'm spate jeremy bring
him he has his own tournament too so I
am see that one for like five years so
it's all the Raiders we go to Ruby Hill
I've been so I'm very connected to the
Raiders when I grew up my my brother
youngest brother was a Raider I was a
packer we had the helmets and we were
just uh and if it can't be if it can't
be the Packers who would you want to win
the Super Bowl it can't be the pack but
can't be the Packers I like the Chargers
mm-hmm I just think the charge Phillip
Rivers I love them he'll they'll never
achieve it but that's the team I like is
the charge on huh what about him
baseball if it can't be if it can't be
the Brewers well I would think boy I'd
like a small market team so it would
have to be that's very you know like
that
no enough it's I would because they did
it you know what not as much as people
in my division hate the Cubs I don't
really hate the Cubs as much to do the
Cardinals the Cardinals always are
winning in your box is that a Cardinal
fan yeah oh yeah Carter I would think I
would wish the Brewers would actually
steal from those organizations they're
winners the winners that and the reason
the Brewers won't do any things because
everybody in the team is never been at a
championship on a championship team you
know the coach counsel is but he's it
doesn't mean it can't motivate the team
so when you don't have players that know
what it's like to win and you need guys
that are winners the only good guy they
have now that I think is just taking
over the team is Moustakas because he's
been there with the Kansas City and
Kansas City when they won the World
Series good when Kansas City won the
World Series six of those guys are
Brewers including the coach I think the
problem with the Brewers the same
problem that the Oakland Athletics have
even though they're doing very well here
they're great shitty
owners who are just like they're still
nickel and diming everything it's more
about making a dollar than it is winning
it's like there's too many greedy
[ __ ] crazy competitive billionaires
out there for these for these leaks to
have owners that don't try to win it all
cost and the problem is it's a good old
boys network and they'll never kick the
Oakland the owner of the Oakland
Athletics out no matter how many decades
of running a team into the ground
they'll never kick them out and that's
what's gonna hurt that that team should
be great oh the Athletics were a
legendary team down that hasn't been
jack [ __ ] for years doesn't article in
the ESPN came out last week it's about
the other GM's and all the they're
hiring already from Harvard and Yale
that are doing stats and Analects which
isn't bad because the Billy but it's
losing Jason Werth and then goose
Gossage they're just going
it's unwatchable look at the Dodge and I
say it's true because this Stern's is
our GM from Harvard and he's just this
guy I sure he's smart he never played
baseball I don't you know you just stick
to you got a Dodger you got even go by
the book that you throw in a picture and
I automatically know and I'm just
because I study the Brewers I go we're
gonna lose this guy's gonna lose it's
this guy named Knebel he's god-awful
he's just blown nine games in the last
forty day leads and he's the guy that
hit the grand slay every thing wrong
with this guy he was our closer all-star
last year I said this guy's not an All
Stars guy blows I was right we've got
all these pitchers that just give up
runs and runs and runs it's like would
you jump here from Kansas City is
Moustakas yeah yeah he's he's doing
great to look at the Dodgers we lost the
World Series because of analytics
you know we this team here Dodger fan
huge okay Hugh so that game last year
the that was the probably the best World
Series and the best was a 14 to 30 what
was that final score of the second of
the game six I don't know why next
remember was like 13 to 12 they they
came back from four down there and then
the other team came back it was like
and that was like an insane game of just
I mean home run after home run idiot
after I mean we just making dumb plays
at the dumb place he's gotten smarter
but the problem is is that Dave Roberts
and Andrew Friedman our analytics guys
and I don't mind analytics when you're
deciding on who to draft or who to sign
but when it comes to the game you got to
let the feel the game baseball is all
feel you got a feel for the game if a
guy's hot you ride them yeah hi guys
cold you sip not this guy Dave Roberts
we scored 21 game was it get you 12
did we score 21 at 24 24 yeah and that's
the picture that's our best picture that
pitch that day they said chocen this
case pitching today yeah 20 and I go are
you kidding me what I was at that Siri
that that three guys and I in that game
hit two home runs
none of them played the next day like
what are you doing it doesn't make sense
and also I agree with this please the
when you have a picture that's in the
bullpen and they throw two innings
[ __ ] cares go nine innings these they
rest their arms are you seriously you
pitched 30 pitches and you're you got to
have a day or two of rest oh I don't get
it I don't really don't get that when
your best guys are I mean back and it's
they have 70s or whatever everybody was
nine inning pitchers the starters they'd
go nine yeah when a Baltimore but they
had Palmer God they had that like what
was the receiver know Mac where they had
the four 20-game winners yeah on a
pitching staff the Orioles when they had
to participate and they had oh yeah if
that was the debt was when pitchers to
go nine innings or a horse I'd read a
20-game winning season I mean like they
just pitch the problem is is these
unions are trying to make it so these
guys can play longer yeah look at the
NBA they're trying to space out the game
more rest more this sucks why so they
can play longer and care and I get that
but it hurts the game yeah and they make
so much money anyways it's I'm not have
like I said best boy you guys are
basketball basketball
yuge one Laker basketball
a clipper see I like the Clippers ten
times more than Lakers oh and I got into
games I've been to quite a few games and
especially now if all these all these
high-end players are gonna force their
way to Lakers nobody's gonna make any
deals ever with the Lakers they're
actually gonna work their ass off to
make sure Lakers don't get players you
know when I get two on the road I could
travel I do he said I'm week on week off
traveling so when the season comes to
basketball if I'm in a city like I was
at the New Orleans and there I say can I
get tickets and they actually gave me
tickets when you go to a game in a
different state arena mm-hmm it's so
much more enjoyable of the hassle first
of all going to LA with the parking with
the whole house so you get tickets how
can you not enjoy the game so you look
at it and you're watching like I saw the
Bucs a few places on the road I was like
okay this is this is basketball that I
love seeing him in Utah or seeing them
yeah yeah I love it more than me going
to Staples Center of going god this
traffic is killing me in dude I went to
what the first year the Rams were here I
went to like maybe the second home game
wasn't even a preseason game at calcium
at the Coliseum and I took the train
there which dropped you off right in
front of the [ __ ] stadium and Trump
from where from like the west side okay
and I saw then I see the first time I
see parking $80 8-0 oh yeah the ticket
was 65 yeah I went to the charger game
this year charger game with Ron Pearson
yeah you know Ron Pearson yeah
Ronde so we go to eat gives me ticket to
meet him at the game great comic so I go
there parking my car 100 bucks
I was $100 I see Lube tune and filter
change my tires rotated I was like I
swear to you I hate it no I said where's
the turnaround but but I was at a good
the stadium is small it's a great venue
because every seats really pretty good
yeah it's such a small Stadium would
only be like 30,000 or something that's
right how is that hundred one hundred
dollars and people were doing it but I
turn around I was like it just makes you
hate
well hey and you hate the whole thing of
my god people are paying it they're
getting $100 $100 that's that's a head
of lettuce at Whole Foods no no no no no
yeah Wisconsin's 20 bucks 20 30 about
two organizations that aren't from LA
moving till I go we could charge whoever
we want to let's Jack them on to and
it's like listen Ellie's a weird town in
that we expect to pay out literally all
of our [ __ ] pay off our [ __ ]
but man when it comes to parking it's
the one thing that drives us [ __ ]
nuts well because we pay so much fun
right so you're like when I get when I
see a movie I know the movies are cost
me $18 for each ticket
popcorns eight dollars waters five dogs
I'm gonna pay on my oh and now you want
eight dollars for parking on top of that
you seem like you could sneak food in
prison I'll hide [ __ ] gummy bears
well I got a hot dog in my ass right now
these kids are working ass like that is
dude I'll buy kids tickets at the movie
theater and then talk up the guy when I
go I walk in like Ed Norton from the
score I so I do the that's his
impression of a bought baby that was
Austin that was a good Norton are you
playing the drums during this whole
episode yeah Jesus Christ awesome baby
so uh god I was gonna ask you another
sports question so well we're about
marking oh yeah well we're talking about
parking but so are you going when you go
to your all four people going to the
Rams games to Colosseum because you park
on someone's lawn and you know it's
lower income there and they're charging
what thirty bucks to park there yeah I'm
all afford them making some Oh way more
it way more than the other my car twice
it gotten broken into at the Coliseum oh
really
yeah I got broken into twice in the same
season
no I don't think so but I do and you're
off I still didn't have the guy that
broke into your car right here oh yeah
anyone's talking huh if you want to ship
could I have the car seat veggies in the
baby chirps hey you're on with kato
kaelin what do you want to talk about
[Applause]
[Music]
please welcome to the show
UFC legend won the greatest fighters
ever fight loves to do catnip and all
the other fun drugs he loves the smell
[ __ ] computer spray you'll like me I
have tender vitals yes George st. Pierre
how are you George collection okay
how many dinosaur teeth you out I am
trying to get the Wow
now Georgia hey it's your buddy old
buddy Jason Tebow here um I recently
read maybe yesterday the day before that
you don't think that you are top five of
all time fighters is that true Jesus
Christ
are you a UFC guy III did a sports show
called tailgater Kato and one of my dear
friends is Fabiano IHA and I George I'm
sure you know Fabiano he's known for the
armbar
yeah George are you friends I think
Bobby Aaron's from Brazil are you guys
buddies he's got a few belts too
he's got a few belts and still training
and he introduced me to all the Gracie's
and well all your friends do train it
okay no any Thai boxing no I I did well
Bruce Lee was famous for Jeet Kune Do
so I did that for a while so I did that
JKD
yeah I did that but now I did like nine
marathons under if you know I ran the L
a few time
in Orange County I accidentally did a
marathon yes Boz give me a chased by
police dogs 26 miles yeah cuz parking
was too crazy everywhere yes no I did me
a few of those marathon finished the one
from 1989 still running
but I did marathons and I was gonna be
my act so I used to you guys see the the
Simpson the FX series the guy who played
me Billy Magnussen who played Kato for
the FX series all you know going hey I
just want me what you know like I guess
how you if you're an actor I I went to
acting Academy and I can't believe it in
called even regardless ki cuz he made
his choice his mind up but he did an
interview after the fact this guy was so
kind to me
I have a clothing line called slacker
and it's a inactive wear bought it for
the entire cast and crew oh that's cool
really really very top shelf guy anyways
we we tweeted a few times and became you
know I said friends but you got very
cool so yeah he became he was he played
Kato
so they had that scene in there where
he's running a beach I used to run no
sweating 10 miles like that my hip is so
bad I swim every day talking about how
much ass you were getting today I didn't
say that way but yeah I did I it was the
it was good baby
George sounds like you have a baby get
him he's got him in a leg lock well yeah
it sounds like to me maybe might have
just gotten somebody pregnant I don't
know if you were abducted by aliens I've
got a few of you guys talking to George
Lapierre not the fighter
how much like who is this chick you
knocked up by the way George is she Ron
or she just throw you a baby and take
off and maybe run a marathon her too
because there's legal matter does it
rhyme with Ronda Rousey Oh
rhyme with bite Fanny Oh George listen I
know you're Jerry Jerry bed knob listen
pal of what's going on Joe st. Pierre
calls in hi I'm [ __ ] kitty litter just
hi talking about aliens that's what we
do
hey George uh real quick who do you got
khabib or McGregor McGregor I like that
you don't know it's Gomez who do you who
do you have winning
I mean who how do you have them Lodi how
does he win I think so before the fight
yeah you can't go to bed T I said they
put odds up that baby is I took all
George during this filming of look who's
talking three Hey so let's get so much
ass talk about know about it wasn't it
wasn't that you know I I saw I traveled
before trial before this ice to MC
Hawaiian Tropic and I used to MC car
shows if you know that all the girls new
car shows right this one pre-trial I had
an actual life before I'm try and I you
know I've had my sag card for over 38
year whatever
right so it wasn't it I just became
famous so all the people would go look
at now he's got a girl not old look at
this and they would hate that people
just hated me if I went to the premier
which I did before they would just hate
so the week before yourself what would
they do they would be like hey cuz I
could hear under breath what the [ __ ] is
he doing oh that piece of [ __ ] and Orick
would love me or hate me so the week
before the murders actually happen I
tested for a movie and my buddy he was
the exec producer on it with the guys
called the Farrelly's it was called Dumb
and Dumber
the week before my life was getting all
these great readings for films so I read
for the Jeff Daniels role my hair was
long it was the hole and Erin Meyerson
he's a he's great he's you know he gave
me the script three months before it
says you got to read this this is cougar
and do it at New Line Cinema blah blah
blah I said oh my god this is great so I
met with Rick Montgomery and there are
so many parts in the film so I just said
obviously wasn't get Jeff Daniels role
with Jeff Daniels a great actor but I
was getting there where it was like this
kind of happening and then you just got
the kibosh and then my life well it just
I was like hot when um I say hot nobody
wanted to speak to me nothing it was
because I was a caricature of myself so
was impossible so it was but but by the
way not this is not me saying oh shoot
my life no not at all this is just
saying this is just saying how that how
life changes so over 24 years ago in the
meantime I wrote something that with a I
know no mic mic jigglin my dear friend
of your and Nick swardson's and all that
so we wrote something it's called wrong
place wrong time or people's life
changes in an instant not just mine but
there's other documented K of people
yeah what if what if this happened what
if I took that door instead of that door
sliding doors yeah when it's Paltrow so
we wrote something and we can't say what
the deal we have but it's it's going
I've always said this to you I've always
said this about you is that you like you
I could see you have been the Ryan
Seacrest coulda woulda shoulda your your
energy is always wonderful I mean
every time we hang out it's always fun
to talk you have great energy you're
very the way you present yourself is and
I totally love people it's like it was
guys so the Ryan Seacrest story is this
because this is great done you're like
no no but this is like it's so I had a
radio show on Kayla sex before Stern
like Stern was on before me and and then
I was on with over late Ken overs
terrific and Olson from Brady Bunch more
jobs in a New York Jamaican yeah all
great stuff and so I wrote a show it was
called house guest and I did it with a
guy named Dan first you were Quentin
Tarantino I'm just named up and show
these guys that I worked with people
that I've got major credits so he wrote
something I went into a pitch meeting at
Fox in 10 seconds they bought it and
said we get it I get dropped off in the
middle of nowhere I have no money a
suitcase closed I have to knock on doors
and find a place to live it was funnier
than [ __ ] great great we filmed the
pilot and and while that's going on it
was sold to a company called Fremantle
they do American Idol yeah so before
American Idol comes in they say Kato you
got to come in here and we're looking
for hosts for this new show nobody knows
what it is yet so I go in to the cat I
have an office there so I already know
I'm aware and everybody knows me there
it's like oh you know Kate was kind of
funny and blah blah blah blah blah and
the office I have is Bob Barker's he
never shows up at free man always be in
Santa Monica my office is on near the
beach it's gigantic I'm thinking this is
just [ __ ] great again so I'm going in
for this show and no nose American Idol
is I'm just going to read it so I go in
there and then the producer of my show
says it's a conflict of interest you
can't even go in this so we can't you're
not gonna get this part so a guy named
Brian Dunkleman goes in ridin him for
long time he [ __ ] himself didn't he I
don't know I don't have that sort of
that story is a Seacrest would come up
to me during my radio show he had a show
in San Francisco so I met him a few
times when he came to LA way before Idol
and goes hey listen your show you got
the best [ __ ] radio show I've ever
heard because it was mine was called the
fastest two hours in radio I would just
it was before podcast it was just me
riffing
roofing in always had something to say
so he listened to that and that was my
Ryan seekest story that he becomes
American Idol when it was right there in
front of me yeah and like you said I
think it's I think it's gonna happen it
takes listen dude you're wonderful do
you think that I've always said that I
don't know if I'm a believer in God or
whatever it is but do you ever think
like actors that hit or their young that
it hits them at the wrong time yes they
turn to drug or they have nothing so I
think like when you're get old you're
like well I can't really do any I'm not
gonna do drugs or screw around it's like
all right it's like it's timing to go
and just go focus and do this and I
think that look at Marc Maron I look at
Joey Diaz these guys I didn't hit two
they were either in almost 50 or well
into their forties and they are hating
so hard and they could take advantage of
it now you see happen more and more
some people hate young and they could
take advantage of it and they ride it
and then some people they get it so I
see all these young guys in the county
so and God bless them to dune gray but
they get like one thing they're showing
up in Lamborghinis and I'm like and it's
so funny to watch because I see it
happen over and over and over again and
it's like I know if I would have hit
Barry I'm very blessed in my career is
doing wonderful things right now but I
know if I would have hit very early I
would have just worked my way out of
Hollywood I was such a piece of [ __ ] I
was such and was that was a piece [ __ ]
was just I was such a paranoid ah angry
guy that I just I didn't have I didn't
realize just let people be people like
he can't control anything and I I want
to right all the wrongs do you blame it
on you and you think that it's that your
base of friends you hung out with at
that time no it was based on the fact
that I was raised by two paranoid human
beings that kind of told me like don't
take [ __ ] and you know some of it
disrespects you you scorch the earth and
that that was kind of what I and I was
so blessed because I sing about either
going when I was young either going to
New York City or the Vegas to start
comedy and thank God I went to Vegas so
I could burn all the bridges there cuz
those bridges lead to nowhere and I love
Vegas it's a wonderful comedy scene now
but back then I would just scorch the
earth and like now I just realized just
let it go
yeah and it's like a blessing right now
I mean dude III when I work you I'm like
this guy is fire dude it's gonna happen
there you like talent Rises well I was
that where I did the ID but I do the I
don't do a lot of comedy but I love
hosting because audiences in LA they're
really tough on me if I go to like I go
out of LA or he just did a thing in
Canada and I'm doing this stuff people
are so appreciative and I you know I I
hate doing the OG stuff but I have to do
three minutes to get out of the way and
it's just really sort of you have to
acknowledge it yeah I acknowledge it I
do it but I have you know I think it's
pretty good stuff on it and I just did a
gig with Murray Langston the unknown
comic and Jimmy Walker in Buffalo it was
so [ __ ] these guys first of all Murray
Langston you know yeah this guy could
have he's still great and very
successful but he when the gong shows
going
this guy could have been a major major
major major multi gazillion there he is
I mean I know Murray very very well and
he's just he's a genius guy and his his
whole thing about life and love and it's
like he's this all positive and it's
like when you meet a guy like that and
when he's not his like gold yeah this
guy is just real so a man that's why I'm
blessed to have him as a very dear
friend I can do it you know Joe okay
Murray what do you think of this and
that this is a guy who goes this is
funny this is great I mean we're doing a
bargain you I was Adam hunters go yeah
yeah yeah you just like the dime yeah
and I'm like dude just breathe it's all
good yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's all
good like I was I was on Instagram like
I saw Kathy Griffin and like at the dime
I know I saw her on if she was something
she posts on Instagram and it was just
like I felt like I rose Twitter I just
felt I feel really bad for her because
she has so much in life but she's so
focused on what she doesn't have
and she's like like Donald Trump Jr's
new girlfriend posted something and she
was like oh she's lying look at this and
I'm like you've been a photo detective
like you have the opportunity like to
travel the world sell out [ __ ] like
enjoy your life man like you're just
fighting this fight that no but
cares about just enjoy the little
[ __ ] things man yeah
I used to hang out with normal lot
didn't you yeah no I love norm people
would always say what happened to you
and norm
nothing happened Norman i norm got busy
I got busy so in this and Norman I used
to golf and I got him really loved
basketball but we played at this fair he
loves gambling I don't he does anymore I
haven't see I saw what the karma story
like I definitely definitely thought
that he does yeah so uh why I know he
did but so I didn't wait back to that
and that by the way can't me it's not
good yes and you know what you guys
aren't no sports very well the worst
thing you can do I've ended some
relationships I've had two broken
remotes and I've told girls I go you
gotta leave now quick because I'm I'm
going kind of insane go it's so bad that
when the Packers would lose on a Sunday
first of all it's at 10:00 a.m. here
your entire Sunday's room it's just rude
it's just like I become the ugliest
person I don't even like me so I gotta
go swim I gotta I get that way without
money on the game yeah oh yes money I'm
so yes yep this is no money I imagine
what it's like with money how involve
it's a fight I can't walk that's why I
never will ever bet on any of my teams
people always try to get me to bet them
you know football or bet on Cubs game
like now I'm not comes into the World
Series you want me to bet on that now
just to triple my jinx you never do that
and I believe in the jinx I believe that
all stuff that's stupid I can't vote up
bet on my team's because I'll always bet
for them to win even when it's like the
oh I would never bet against my team but
if I bet on my team and then they lose
now I'm not only do I have the regular
loss rage right now I'm [ __ ] mad at
myself for betting on it as well yeah
well I do you guys remember the game
last year was a the Packers play the
Cowboys and the Packers were winning 21
like I think eight it was like a weird
score but it's halftime Packers are up
by three touchdowns so this is the
playoff game if you remember and so my
buddy we're at the Claim Jumper in
Burbank watch this cuz I have a big
table of like nine guys so my buddy's
girlfriend walks in and Brett when she
walked in the Cowboys got a touchdown I
her leave I said I said you got it and
my friend would complete but I was I
said I've got it I said I said you got
to get out of here I go you're a nice
person but you [ __ ] after leave you
start almost but she's always kidding
and then she start bawling and I was
like you gotta leave I said and so my
friends all my friends said [ __ ] Cato
take it easy so I said okay then at
least go out and walk back in so that's
the game were Roger that's the overtime
game the overtime game are Aaron Rogers
that that that that scramble and hits
Jared cook for that completion where we
hit the field go and that is probably
one of the greatest players you guys I
don't remember I totally remember it was
the one of the greatest my girlfriend is
even bigger Dodger fan than I am like
she's she likes like preseason baseball
spring trainings yeah I'll go to spring
training and she just loves it and like
if she if the Dodgers are doing well and
then such good [ __ ] and she just walked
in she'll go outside and sit on the
patio what what happened I was five
nothing brewers five nothing brewers but
trust me oh I'm I'm I could read my mom
was the worst [ __ ] manager in the
history of [ __ ] times today I just
started this I said I'm not watching her
I said listen the Brewers are Brewers
started out a stool and other just loose
stool and I go it's mo I go
Curley council most earns and Larry a
pistachio I said the worst organization
in baseball for not making the team
better and that's what they did they
didn't make the button Moustakas they
did not do anything with it
we have no if we go to a wild card game
you've got to have that one closing but
you got to have that one pitcher it's
one game yeah I don't have it that one
game is key yeah you [ __ ] three arms
with Jensen now but Dodgers have
pitchers yeah but we don't start we've
lost four games rope because we have no
closer yeah we know it's lost the ninth
inning for Dame's in a row they've got
to take a starter into the closing roll
I don't know if that's there I deal with
it Kate Amara all right it's analytics
and it's [ __ ] crazy
they got a they got to have a starting
pitcher well they're gonna make the play
I think looking at Hubie I think there
are three games behind in the wild for
the wild card game yeah did we at Zack
Greinke he's getting shower behind
[ __ ] Colorado now oh all right I
swept them did they know they won like
three out of four yeah it's baseball but
this is the when people say certain
things on the on the Twitter feed like
hey relax
first of all I hate that when they say
that because they don't know what's
going on in my mind yeah and you go
crazy it's like no listen I see the game
I see the mistakes they're gonna make
and I like I said five zero third inning
Cubs just beat that good Grand Slam that
was the bastard that was amazing luckily
I was watching that live yeah that was
that was a game that I that I would like
I mean I don't even watch you know like
seventh I almost turned it off yeah most
people I had on the background and then
once bases were loaded I like just close
my laptop I'm like I'm gonna give this a
chance
oh my god and that guy's great that's
his 90th major league at-bat when you
hit that was it boat
yeah boat huh huh yeah he said the fire
I mean he just he's he hasn't been in
the major leagues all season pretty much
that battery nothing and hit a grand
slam walk I think of being surgery IMAX
serger who you just hear it every way
hit it the sound of you're like that's
gone the guy pitches eight innings and
he's got the 3-0 game going going okay I
got a victory watch when he scores they
rip his jersey oh they just beat the
[ __ ] out of this guy and then after that
he hugs Bill Murray I don't know what's
better hitting the Grand Slam or [ __ ]
[ __ ] look how happy a man there jumping
him in so they hug him so I I'm gonna
name drop I get invited to Bill Murray's
golf tournament so rad oh so great said
st. Augustine Golf Hall of Fame so I
just did it my first year that I did it
I had so much fun the Murray bro who
else was in that Brian doyle-murray bars
and who else Oh every murder there's
nine of them I think but I mean what are
the celebrities they have it's the event
starting age huh bill some older
probably that had to feel so good so
then after that not only do you hit a
walk-off Grand Slam at your
[ __ ] in the major league [ __ ] months I
don't know if this should it's not the
Cubs win the World Series or not cat now
can we see it cuz the guy sitting in
front of Bill Murray is on Phillipe like
that moment right before when the Cubs
win the World Series they show Bill
Murray well son bucket I'll tell you
what's a good thing while he's looking
for that is when Bill Murray lost his
son lost the Xavier of Wisconsin
last-second shot because right sitting
ring from look at the same rate problem
who is it you got hit look look right
down there stop
yeah it looks like Bill hit him in the
back of the head you know that is Craig
Gass yeah that was that thought so Craig
Gass that's a Mariners hat yeah well you
that dude how does that guy get that see
that see Craig takes his cameras look at
he's doing yeah look a jackhammer real
quick film um dude that - dude what an
amazing moment be just the be there how
do you get that [ __ ] seat but the guy
next to Murray and the right was
obviously not a fan of Chicago you see
his face yeah he's the guy in the black
hats pissed like [ __ ] we lost oh yeah
yeah Dangerfield looks like a young
Rodney in Caddyshack so you're so you're
at Murray's so who else is that that
thing in Chicago it's no it's in st.
Augustine Florida though I'll call Fame
you know it's one of those four-day
events that people fly in and fly out
but a lot of the they're really a
close-knit family yeah there's a ton of
actors but it's not it was like when
you're like a Timberlake but not that
year so I went two years so he gets
whoever can make it at that tighter it's
it's it's so crowded that you didn't see
anybody in his tents everywhere there's
jam sessions and Bill gets onstage and
they sing it is off the chart fun I'm
very good friends with John Murray who
looks identical to bill yeah so a lot of
people don't know how many I mean knock
at window Murray's been in he's I have a
bunch of pictures of my Instagram Cato
underscore Kalin ke LAN you can see
those pictures so
I know Maryam you my picture that
because I am a huge Chris Lu get a life
fan and go I love this oh I love Chris
cabin boy yeah and so uh I don't know
they'd he had a daughter
he's the Murray - yeah that's brother I
did I said a lot of people don't realize
how many things the brothers man yeah
and so Brian doyle-murray and did you
know he's hilarious in Caddyshack yeah
he's great no but you know cash acts on
the Murray family that's on there uh the
brothers being all caddies yep and yeah
some great stuff so Brian dough
did you know that Chris Elliott daughter
she said SNL or was yeah right so we
said that that was you that's the corner
am i right that's his daughter ride a
voice is in your head I'm amazed yeah
Chris Elliott on it one time when it was
like yeah weird
no she's cute hold on that's his
daughter yeah yeah how hot is the wife
to clean up that mess did that get weird
yeah Chris Elliot's wife that he's
looking at Chris Alex wife oh it's
Cameron Diaz right there right there oh
she's pretty hot she's like a UH worship
I think it's the redhead right there
right there's that his daughter oh well
okay creeper creeper the I didn't know
forever that uh you know Bob Weinstein
yeah I've done golf with that guy he I
think he was super super funny yeah it's
great super funny you know his brother
is Brooks yeah I didn't know that
forever why how hilarious must those
Thanksgiving dinners again that's a
hilarious family right there yeah I did
a few golf events with super David he's
so cool to me and we he just just starts
laughing when he sees me and hold on l
were booked and bought on Super Dave her
brothers
Sam I'm getting knowledge for you here
ah this is the oh my god
and then Joel Murray is the other
brother and he's on whose line is it
anyway
hmm there's another there's a lot of
Murray's there's a lot of
called his Instagram is nine of nine
nine kids if you ever and is I'm saying
that's not sort of to everybody
listening out there if you want to watch
a really funny a Super Dave Osborne
interview yeah madman madman yeah yeah
so many [ __ ] Marie's they're taking
all the goddamn jobs and also friends
the far leaves a lot of Farley's and
Chris went to Marquette that's how many
Farley's are there was John Farley Kevin
Farley and Chris Farley passed away but
Chrissa is a Marquette guy who went
there in the Oneidas Tommy boys wearing
the Marquette coat that's Milwaukee and
that's one of the great great
universities in Milwaukee if you've
never been have you absolutely it is so
vajjis great volvo magazine last week
vogue just to this article and you can
google that too saying milwaukee is the
hidden gem city that no one knows about
i can see that let me tell you so I've
given Milwaukee a couple times where
wonderful just rock clubs it's been a
while oh my god I look they're wonderful
it's wonderful say the problem with
Milwaukee's everybody thinks like
everybody in Wisconsin looks like Packer
fans just like fat sloppy would [ __ ]
cheese dripping out everywhere and I
went there and I was like those people
are wonderful did the women were
extremely attractive yeah it was a nice
area yeah in this it's definitely a
summer city people go sure see Wisconsin
go cold it's cold in the winter but it's
not it's yeah it's New York it's cold
Chicago's gold it's the same exact you
know climate as you call them right
share that hood they're identical
basically Milwaukee is a clean Chicago
and not as many murders yeah there's a
couple Marty Parker but I don't think
that matters the Parkers always heard he
did nothing for the T and he just didn't
fit into the team yeah you know II hate
him walk yeah the Greek freak and then
you have Milton Milton and like there
was no real place for in the plot if we
had again him Brogdon was the upper key
of the year and then he signs with
Chicago and they already have guys at
his position so he's gonna go play and
it it's gonna be around and the Bucks
will make the playoffs the whole thing
over they got a stadium they have now
the arena it's going to be the number
one
now in the America for a while first
state of the Arts brand-new and they've
got all these restaurants around it and
I can't wait to go back to any one more
superstar everyone let's so I thought
was gonna be it but did he blow yeah he
just did make it he's just not right
he's a great oh wow look at that it's
gonna it's gonna be off it's supposed to
look like a giant taco yeah it's it's no
it's gonna tell you thing called to the
cream want to call her every move they
do it they buy me some corny tells no no
no cannoli a baby a cannoli Tommy can
only feel but you can see the I know I
was just there does look like a food so
I got these I got these law commercials
that run in Milwaukee so when you go to
your city law commercial no we're doing
yeah it's me it's me it says it's one
guy you go
hi I'm white and I need a lawyer and
another guy goes hi I'm black I need
somewhere it's a Carlson law clever no
that's an audio oh that's not the Casper
I got a new campaign for the America
California's new law is better than the
you can't the law on what he calling
people live at places a squat squatters
no no no we're being here being the
Airbnb is like a parts of it illegal now
so we started this come on Airbnb is
illegal for tax reasons is something
weird California I don't know but I'm
dancing with you I'm dancing with a
cardinal well that's that's a different
correct that's four it's called guest
house rent rent calm guest house rent
calm that's what the spot is so that's
just the commercial for it but my
commercials Milwaukee its Carlson blah
and Clements but it's a basic legal
Milwaukee law firm and well they had my
competitions William Shatner's comes
from you go back home a lot do you stuff
like a lot of family then [ __ ]
everybody's there yeah yeah and you have
this big family like the Murray's in the
[ __ ] fire lives race your cabinets
huge family huge Caitlin's and I'm not
any like the
let me tell you my dad in restaurants
cheese eating is the it's what do go
there you go hey give it over here
you've got to have some food they just
it's food food food it's like you're on
a cruise you ever see yourself moving
back yeah Johnny
hey Kate engage I work at the Red House
and I'm white right deer hunting bass
fishing and extending credit to all
people I love this I love it it gets
better in the house for me Flight of the
Conchords
let me get the sofa it's perfect for a
black person to expand ik X panic people
I was just in North Carroll asked her to
you that commercial is brilliant oh I
wonder how that company's doing
it's got to be kicking butt that's not
money how they how they pick on it's
brilliant I love it am i right is that
right is that second time we've watch it
on this show it's like the timing of
that could not be any better what's
going on and in North Carolina oh yeah
I'm petrol some money they play that all
the time you ever listen to petrol some
money I never really look like I'm five
seventy dude Petros is the fastest mind
I've ever heard in my life sports-minded
oh yeah what's wrong Johnny we were
gonna watch his commercial I was nowhere
near that but I loved that one much
better than mine isn't it great huh that
is that's also a red house a red house
at the red house furniture store endings
great is that my couch is great for a
black person or white person and so of
my bed is white person black person or
eggs or an ex panic person yeah
expanding you know you know the
commercial out sequels gonna have
Hispanic and Asian oh yeah it's gonna be
like a Benetton commercial you do this
cool ass cosplay stuff right yeah like
what are the after parties like when the
conventions done is it just everybody
goes drinks and well I work for a
company called Wizard World and first of
all Sam most of this is on East Coast or
I do every radio TV show I'm onstage
nine hours as soon as I'm off stage I go
at the hotel we can't even move I move
in my energies and I have to in 9 a.m.
if it's New York over East Coast at 6
a.m. I do a workout before to look fresh
I'm up at like 2:00 a.m. la time whoa
nine hours I'd I tell you I fly home
either Sunday or Monday I mean she gave
him Monday
I can't I have to get a two-hour massage
because I have a bad hip from running oh
my god it is the best job ever it's the
it's grueling as far as energy and I
have to keep it up it's constant people
so I have a main stage and then the
autographs you've been no convention
before of course so you have people
actors that are getting paid lots of
money where they have lines of people
meeting Stanley or or the cast of a
Justice League so you're there and my
stage is in front everybody's got to
walk by me and I'm saying hey coming up
next we'll go some trivia doing the
audience then I'll say the best act of
Ohio today we have the 90s group so it's
constant entertainment of oh bugger
whoever but we have on our stage
consistently from 9:00 a.m. until close
of a magician or a that I have people
come on stage I have a kids contest and
it's it's it's great but I got you
always got because never and rarely take
a break because there's always never
have Boston babies on your hey it's my
awful impression of a Boston baby
so comic-con owns Wizard World know
which the world's largest traveling show
comic-con San Diego's separate where
there's a ton of them this fan dip and
dip and didn't they call it comic-con
though I feel like it's wizard world
like these places it's Wizard World
Comic Con comic-con existe it's a
generic term yeah so were low but we
just got the rights to Asia or China and
Sony so we're gonna probably start going
and we'll never see you again I'm
telling you I said today if I go to Asia
I will get married yeah because I'm
dating asia women yeah yeah it's are you
dating the one the beautiful one is
currently on your couch
you've mentioned how beautiful she was
like right out the gate so she's no
she's terrific
she's not a man couch either
that legal man air B&B air DMV air
[ __ ] bed I get it
doesn't that's Charlie texting me right
now five zero air D&P no Charlie Charlie
okay okay he's a baseball fanatic
we love baseball so we have as you a
picture that's packed there looks like a
Walmart on Christmas yes looking at he
has to talk to every one of those people
for 20 minutes each oh that's that's our
shows so this it Chicago is our biggest
show next week
you gotta go show you some of these
pictures and go to my Instagram it's
hysterical these people of me of talking
these it's really work because you you
do week in week on week off it's with a
day yeah okay so even currently you're
in town this week but this week I will
show her now for the show
she's uh
oh that's just me talking do you have
time tied up in your apartments nav area
say I'm saying we've got Thor I've got
me a Wonder Woman but I'm using the kid
as the Wonder Woman the man and they got
the tag and I go I go that's a Wolfman
okay okay oh did you see the thing with
Tiger Woods please watch my Instagram
because Tiger Woods they do with Jesus
volume this is when he walks in and I
listen this what happens on that a B
they I put it on Twitter it's like it
went semi viral I guess like 8000 right
within first on my world so this one
listen what the announcer says you gotta
go loud here
you hear him say but he goes that's fun
to watch but not get the video so Johnny
its watch it's fun to watch that's when
the girl tiger finishes the girl slaps
him on the ass but then ouch you're
saying it's fun to watch he's not
watching what's going on he's talking
about Tiger getting so close his
girlfriend so I'm just saying who's he
dating now some restaurant tier person's
restaurant I read it of the of the
comments but yeah wizard worlds uh picky
so funny what who you texting Boston
baby yeah she has a phone so what do you
think of time maker get rid of him
get rid of them i watch the playoffs
right really there's a video here yeah
it's alright the announcers so it that
would be an announcer getting fired
again cuz you can't say anything in the
world anymore probably I'm sure you are
where the moms like do they stare at you
at loss yes they stare at you hungry
eyes it's so funny we do a thing at the
end of every show we do cater okey so
it's a they're coming onstage we get the
best people that think they can sing
obviously and okay but in the cities you
have I always have like the Batman's
I've got the entire just all that's
right it's so cool it's a show it really
is a show because you got these
cosplayers they really think they're the
character you get these dudes that think
that they're Wolverine so funny that you
do this this job and then you're also
the one that captured the video of all
these people fighting on the house that
was before the job wait you don't
remember me Chewbacca it's
know how how many how many times do you
do this by 28 City so it's continuous it
doesn't end so it's week on week off
like I said it's a great gig and it's
also getting me ready for the other show
I wrote because I'm super excited for
yellow see I knock away because I've had
obviously a thousand close calls so I
now I just like letting you man you know
buddy I look back at a lot of stuff that
you know my life and like where I
started who I started with where they
are and the fact that you're still in
the game grinded it's like a blessing
there's so many people who just like
call it quits got a job that's sucking
their soul and you know it's like you're
the the beauty of Los Angeles and why we
put up with all this traffic and chaos
and fires earthquakes hundred dollars to
park 100 dollars of Park is because
you're one day away from living your
dreams you're one day away from me able
to afford $100 for one day away from you
know one call when I leave you want to
be able to leave yeah come in when you
have to work economy goal and yes he
asked me before whatever moved to
Wisconsin I'd get a place there for sure
oh I would live it in Chicago no
heartbeat so my heartbeat my sister
she's got what she lives in Milwaukee
but they got a summer home you nobody
goes to cottages and she got this home
that is just if you it's 20,000 square
feet it's on there's five lakes yeah and
there it's a four they built it from
scratch it's $400 a month mortgage yeah
it's so it's so beautiful and then you
take the pontoon boat or the jet skis
whatever and it's a casino and you just
this is I could go oh my god this is so
much fun that's let's they live for
summer I bet you love it and if you want
to make a bet you can go to bet TS hi
brought it up perfectly your sponsor I
love that yeah bet the assignment it's
really great they're they've just read
up with us again we're blessed have them
they've been with us for like five years
they're our favorite sponsor of all the
sponsors say that never again bat dsi
calm or die you use the promo code punch
25 25 and get $25 bag cash
plus they double up whatever your
deposit they double up Oh on a box in
another hundred bucks questions about
that if questioner a date so it's off
out of America or in America it's all
over the place it is a go at you go
online just go to it yeah BAM look at
that I love that and what they did it's
very cool we touched on a little bit and
GSP touch on a little bit
they put a real line up for this Ryan
O'Neal fight and and I mean Ryan O'Neal
and and Lucia Gomez and I think O'Neal
is a minus 135 yeah and I think Gomez is
like plus 200 or something like that so
Gomez is the underdog I don't even know
what we're betting here I'm whether this
chick is wearing underwear or not what
was that bad but yeah guys if you want
to sign up go to bed ts icon music Oh
punch 25 throw the 25 bucks on whoever
you think it's gonna win who do you
battle wink or on Neal the Indiana
porcupine or whatever he calls himself
no what was it yeah Indiana Mongoose
hole it's hard to chant they don't hurt
each other
I hope they both kill each other what
that's how you with this [ __ ] thing
the I hope they both kill each other
that's more work then it's more gigs for
us I don't have to listen either one of
them blablabla anymore that site is that
do you get money I don't do fantasy
football yeah do you guys do it oh yeah
big time so we wanted is that you know
who's trying to figure out how to I
could find time to do it I didn't need
help because usually my Sundays are all
booked with this thing it's like almost
impossible I can't have no TV I'm on the
stage so I go down Wednesday right you
set your team you make money doing
fantasy football well you do the daily
leagues you can you know is that site no
that is an actual betting site that is a
football of betting site to to make they
have ones yeah they have daily ones that
are like you know FanDuel or all these
different ones where you can play a bet
yeah we should get spawn weekly oh I
don't want to buy the energy why don't
we all say we're going to put in
bucks and see whose team has the best
makes the playoffs oh you are a gambling
man I'll do it I'm definitely down
hey what whose energy jobs so you think
you know the devil did I welcome to show
the guy in charge number the
commissioner a commissioner of
punch-drunk fantasy league what's up
brother nothing man just hiding at work
right now
Oh what are you HOT who you hiding from
so he can do this call every
responsibility so I can make this phone
call figure out this okay so you're
definitely in the toilet what I meant is
that the bathroom yeah you're in the
bathroom you're in a bathroom no I'm in
like a flat space with empty wall well
take a [ __ ] there anyways let him know
you were there I need some DNA so tee
dubs how many people do we have in this
league so far so far be Tebow Sammy
yeah I heard Ari's out but I had a
thought about that okay you guys gave
calf for a spot okay so we got one six
left Ronnie's in right now today or
never wanted you I do not know Aaron
does not want join cuz he hates [ __ ] no
I don't like football and I do not like
ruining my Sunday so we have how many
spots open for five I think what what
depends how many how many people we want
to do do we want to do 14 teams to help
you Ripley wants a 14 leagues fine when
I hear someone say how many people you
want to do I have a different thing
going in my mind
uh-huh what do we ten what are the
tri-state well ten is so easy twelve
will go 12 because these guys cry so
that means we got water seven spots open
yeah we cry you cry from the beginning
of the draft to the end and then you had
a great team okay so he we're gonna put
the official number but the time is now
for people who tell us what they want to
do to get
and why you should be in the league was
there anybody who's supposed to be in
the league last year that didn't get in
was there any not really the the thing I
was thinking is do we want to give the
piste Rinker a shot to to repeat well
let's see what let's let's feel it out
some people might go harder than the
paint and raise the stakes
yeah do you think the TAC I should be in
why Johnny I think so yeah he got a guy
so he should be in front he got [ __ ] boy
for life tattooed on his body
no for life he's in the lead I think one
more guy from one more year he wants to
be a super harsh
okay so will Pope [ __ ] boy for life and
maybe he could do a heart around it or
something yeah okay
he's gotta add to every year okay this
is the deal okay every year yeah he can
be the league if he adds something to
the task okay a heart around [ __ ] boy
for life and you're back in the league
yeah if he puts a heart around it yeah
so that's what about the guy that drink
his own piss how's he gonna up his game
bring somebody else's piss Oh God come
on just did it's only 20 ounces big dope
you can chill it he busts out
electrolytes he can chill it if he wants
all right so we'll figure that out guys
if you want be the league so what you're
gonna do want to do yeah send your idea
to punch from fantasy a gmail let us
know what you're gonna do and then just
like last year I guess me and Johnny all
curate that and you guys can make your
choices and the mo figure out when are
the draft will probably be and also I'm
gonna say this Cato you got you you
can't make it to the draft if you don't
say you're gonna sign up and want to be
in the league and then flake on the
draft everybody that I don't want any
aunt anybody Otto drafting no I hate all
that that's worse yo you gotta get
another think about I'm gonna give it
some serious thought I serve one spot
for Cato in case he'll get will give you
a week to think about all right we can
new Gummer number yeah
sit down and figure out if you want
Tuesday but you just caught whatever
21:24 I was asleep they feel like the
fight family should have to be in no
they hate everything yeah that's what
would be good though that's the point
that I want to make what I want to be in
a fantasy football league with a monkey
a chicken two girls that don't know
anything about fantasy football
and then a bunch of people that are like
the guys that tell you how they won
their league every year and they're
geniuses like she could just like hit
the keyboard I'm saying so that's great
so yeah it'll keep her eyes
we'll keep our eyes up those emails a
couple of things I was thinking for Ari
if he's down I mean grits and gravy
could maybe have a spot open for a
co-manager if you wanted to join with me
couple champs see what we can do after
it's dad showing by cowboy last year but
for him literally he'll do nothing all
you ollie would be is just like he'd be
like the sponsor of your team he didn't
even know anything that happened and
it's with his team last year oh yeah Oh
still a bag of Beth and are we gonna put
a bag of s on the line this year yeah we
got to figure out what that whatever
that we have to think of what the champ
wins yeah well cash is king
yeah like I don't want to do it unless
it's cash cash is king 20 bucks I don't
know could do that he set up a bit more
some kind of thing like that pretty how
bad do you want it like PayPal venmo
- yeah what's going on every day
something new
I don't know can't forget the BevMo back
down what is that how creepy for someone
who's creep and Casper's creep and maybe
we should keep it spot for whoever's
willing to pay the most to get in so
we'll make a a mix of fight nanny
talking about all the filth she's into I
[ __ ] everybody who is that who was
that mr. good night nanny that was you
right there yeah that's up and she's
talking about her love a black day oh
it's all taken out of context of what it
really was was you guys were talking
about something and then I said oh
that's so awkward like you yeah I love
your [ __ ] and then you guys cut out just
amazing yeah maybe we did that maybe we
did maybe we didn't yeah we all get peed
on I like in Peter its flanks being peed
on it's just like a lot of come I'm not
on gold that won't come down that won't
come back she's gonna start her own
podcast white guys can pee on you cuz
it's a lot of cob yo guys okay
you gotta go dude I'm yeah I gotta go
keep an eye out for those emails people
can check the punch-drunk twitter hey
yeah for any info what is the name of
your team gonna be this year I Brooklyn
gravy now there we go hey we gotta cut
him off right when he's in his website
I'm surprised he didn't all right you're
on with Kato final call today before we
call it a day final call all right all
right
what's going on fam how are you guys
what's up buddy a lot of Canadians on
the show love Canada love can you hear
me yeah we can hear you are you Canadian
no dude I'm not I'm uh I'm from Boston
originally I live out on the west coast
now baby into the back of the Comedy
Store
oh great dude how are you good magic on
earth the
you guys I love you've been a longtime
listener just want to make sure that
we're all team O'Neil over here yeah for
sure
yeah for sure I mean I called it earlier
I called it early yeah yeah I think
that's acute are you gonna go to the
side so I wanted to say [ __ ] great to
have you back on the show man for awhile
I was worried you weren't gonna be I
can't leave dude I can't quit these guys
I just need a break once in a while I
think every July I'm gonna take a break
I saw yeah I don't have anything
pertinent yet to really call them but
they just wanted to call and say hello
can if I still have that gift from Peru
for you send her some piss yeah she
loves a lot of or a lot of curse and
piss in a box
Hey are you in Boston or LA are you in
Boston or LA are you in Boston or LA LA
right now right now I'm actually in
Boston visiting family but I'm usually
in La Porte one okay Jared we're coming
to Boston tonight right yeah no
pretending we're staying at your place
well I can get you your gift when you
hear that it's like a world traveler no
no no yes yeah I can bring let me know
when you're in town shoot me a text and
I'll bring you that gift please do
something tells me it's a neck pillow
from an Air Force does Jesus Christ not
cool Candice has a gift for you how cool
are you with getting a baby
I think I could sell that for what do
you think why isn't she for sale they
sit like I want to keep you make another
one I've been watching I don't want you
to be time I just wanted to say hello
spread some love welcome back buddy
I'm Miss Bates out how do I look you
look great
right that was guys it's been a great
show I had a lot of fun I'm hungry so my
guys final thoughts
anybody final thoughts Kato final
thought final thoughts I'm glad I did
your show I knew so much I really I feel
the same way about you honestly I always
said that you're you know certain people
you kind of hang and like you go to a
place like the comedy stuff is kind of
lonely in this form it gets known it's
hard but you are open with the heart I
can feel it and I've know that for the
first time I met you so I said like
here's a good dude thank you so certain
people that I get along with it really
cool Jeff Richards by the way also very
Craig house oh yeah I'd love give my
best and please of all you followed me I
would tell people that because I'm not
big on the Instagram but now I'm
starting to do these little stories and
the stories have got me like nine jobs
so I think that I keep it going to
underscore
kela kato kaelin normal did they
somebody already take that as a few of
the fake ones yeah
somebody faked one yeah suck it all
right like nanny have fun in Boston
that's fun travel safe we'll see you
guys in break you're pregnant again